Kanye West calls Gigi Hadid a privileged
Karen and a zombie as their online Feud
heats up I mean I was expecting
let's rewind the rapper made headlines
earlier this week for wearing a white
lives matter shirt at his Yeezy season 9
presentation at Paris Fashion Week why
did she do that and what did it mean I
do certain things from a feeling I like
I just I just channeled the energy it
just feels right
it's using
a gut instinct a connection with God
and
just brilliant shortly after Vogue
editor Gabriella karifa Johnson
criticized the designer for sporting the
controversial slogan yay clapped back
taking aim at the journalist by slamming
her fashion sense I'm just extremely
happy can you tell by my face
well Gigi was having none of that and
defended Gabriella on Instagram calling
the rapper a bully and a joke then after
Tremaine Emery the creative director of
supreme called out Kanye for using the
late fashion designer Virgil ablo's
death in his victim campaign claiming he
bad mouth Virgil before he died of
cancer last year Gigi swooped into the
comments to second that saying yay
didn't treat Virgil like a friend some
people will believe it that's when the
rapper screenshot Gigi's comment circled
it and posted it to Instagram writing
that he's not going to get ran over by
Hollywood again quote Gigi you a
privileged Karen you were born with a
silver spoon in your mouth you're a
zombie you speak up here but didn't
speak up when my child was kidnapped on
her birthday the Grammy winner who
shares four children with his ex Kim
Kardashian previously claimed he wasn't
invited to his four-year-old daughter
Chicago's birthday party in January
which Kim has adamantly denied people
don't see the context behind it and
while Gigi has yet to respond to the
easy designers latest diss she isn't the
only one to weigh in on Kanye's Antics
we don't have to condemn Kanye or cancel
him before he doesn't have to go crazy
but at the same time you know saying You
Gotta Be You you gotta understand like
your actions did he chimed in on the
controversy during a chat with The
Breakfast Club Wednesday praising yay
for being a free thinker before calling
the fashion Choice tone deaf meanwhile
Haley Bieber backed Gabriella on
Instagram writing gkj all day every day
and Jaden Smith who was in attendance at
the Yeezy show tweeted that he had to
dip explaining why he walked out quote I
don't care who it is if I don't support
the message I'm out
[Music]